hi hi how are you tonight we will be
honoring the work you know what I can't
do it because we're upset Oh are we
upset you know what you guys don't want
to know
we're P Oh frankly I'm seeing red I'm
ticked off you know you know what you
guys don't know what's going on you
don't that I'm teed off I'm steamed I
you know what hmm
I can't do this soon we're sorry we're
too upset
we're upset to do this guys guys
we're not mad that was an act we were
acting mm-hmm we just know there are a
lot of Directors here tonight
I just wanted them to know we would do
more than comedy oh that was my line
well I guess it's mine no son
how would you know you were always gone
when I was a kid see acting
something other than acting that were
passionate about his own production
design look I'm sorry I can't do this
see we crying yep here are the nominees
for achievement in production design the
irishman production design by Bob Shaw
set decoration by Regina graves
Jojo rabbit production design by Rob
inson set decoration by Norris October
1917 production design by Dennis Gassner
set decoration by Lise and ales once
upon a time in Hollywood production
design by Barbara wing set decoration by
Nancy Haig parasite production design by
Amy Hatsune set decoration by Cho Rong
boom once upon a time in
[Applause]
first Oscar and nomination for bargain
lane
the second Oscar and
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you to the Academy and thank you
and we share this with our incredible
art department and my partner in crime
decorator Nancy Hague and mostly to
Quentin Tarantino for writing an epic
masterpiece and letting us take this
wild ride with him
thank you a huge shout out to all the
people that helped put us here tonight
the craftsmen the the construction guys
the painters our prop master Chris Hall
and of course my gang mark and Sarah and
Jonesy and Adam and everybody I
appreciate it so much
[Applause]